ليست هذه الجبهه الوحيده المشتعله على
اطراف ضخموت فالخطوط الخلفيه بين فاجنر
والجيش الروسي مستعره بتقاذف الاتهامات
بعضها تجاوز الخطوط الحمر
الناس يجب ان يمتلكوا حريه التعبير عن
ارائهم الجنود العاديون هم الوحيدون فوق
اي انتقاد تصريح وصف بقنبله من العيار
الثقيل لمتزعم قوات فاجنر الروسيه في اخر
تطور للخلافات الدائره بينه وبين قياده
الجيش الروسي
اعتقد ان قانون مكافحه التشويه السمعه يجب
ان لا يسري على اركان القياده اي انا
ووزير الدفاع والقاده الاخرين الذين
يرتكبون او يمكن ان يرتكبوا الاخطاء اثناء
عمليه عسكريه خاصه
بريجوجين لم يتوقف عند هذا الحد بل ذهب في
هجومه الجديد الى اتهام قياده الجيش
الروسي بمنع حتى معاوي لحفر الخنادق عن
عناصر فاتنر بامر جعل القتال والتقدم
صعبين عليهم في بطنه
وفقا لوزاره الدفاع البريطانيه فان تصميم
الجيش الروسي للسيطره على بلده فوهليدار
بدونيسك ياتي في اطار التنافس بين
الجانبين ومحاوله لمضاهات فاجنر في باخموت
كذلك توقع تحليل لمعهد دراسات الحرب في
واشنطن ان يسعى الجيش الروسي للقضاء على
مقاتل فاغنر في ساحات القتال بينما توقع
تقرير امريكي ان تصبح فاجنر قوه عسكريه
موازيه للجيش الروسي بعد ضمها 50 الف
مقاتل مع استمرار تقاذف الاتهامات بين
الطرفين تبقى جبهه اوكرانيا صامده الى حين
نهايه المعركه بين فاغنر والجيش